Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件现在正在发生、让人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的管道，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up, we've got a special treat for you in this episode as we welcome back the
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？你当然想。快去查看我的 Linktree 链接（Dr Marianne Trent），或者关注我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。接下来，在本期节目中我们将迎来一位特别的嘉宾，欢迎我们的老朋友——
incredible Phil, a trainee clinical psychologist. We are unravelling the rich tapestry of LGBTQ plus identity and the crucial world of research into this space. Get ready for a candid conversation that goes beyond boundaries as we explore the intersectionality of LGBTQ plus experiences and dive into the importance of understanding cross-cultural differences. Whether you are a psychology enthusiast, an ally or just someone seeking fresh perspectives, this episode promises compassion, insights and a whole lot of heart. Hit that play button and join us in this illuminating exploration of the diverse and ever-evolving landscape of LGBTQ plus identity. Hope you will find it so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a
优秀的菲尔（Phil），他是一名临床心理学硕士生。我们将探讨 LGBTQ+ 身份认同那丰富多彩的面貌，以及深入该领域研究的关键意义。准备好迎接一场打破常规的坦诚对话吧，我们将探讨 LGBTQ+ 经历的交叉性（intersectionality），并深入了解理解跨文化差异的重要性。无论你是心理学爱好者、盟友，还是仅仅在寻找全新视角的人，这期节目都将为你带来同理心、深刻见解和满满的真心。点击播放按钮，与我们一起加入这场对 LGBTQ+ 身份认同多元化且不断演变的前沿风景的启发性探索。希望你会觉得它非常有用。欢迎收听“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名
qualified clinical psychologist. I do try and keep my finger on the pulse and help you become aware of really important issues, whether or not you've got access to supervision, whether or not you've got access to people where you can ask questions and learn things about their lives. Dissectionality is a really big and important issue and our ability to reflect upon our own lives as well as being aware upon individual differences for other people's lives can be really, really important. Today's episode is going to be doing just that. We're welcoming back Phil, who is a third year trainee. And let's dive in and see what we have got to say and I'll catch you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome back the wonderful Phil Pamperlove to our podcast.
合格的临床心理学家。我一直在努力紧跟时代脉搏，帮助你了解真正重要的问题，无论你目前是否能获得督导，也无论你身边是否有可以随时提问并了解他们生活的人。交叉性是一个非常宏大且重要的问题，我们反思自己生活的能力，以及对他人生活中个体差异的觉察，可能会变得非常非常重要。今天的节目正是要探讨这些。我们将再次邀请菲尔做客节目，他是一名三年级实习生。让我们深入了解一下他的分享，我们稍后再见。嗨，我想再次欢迎精彩的菲尔·帕姆普洛夫（Phil Pamperlove）来到我们的播客。
You might well remember our chat in episode 113 of the podcast where Phil and I were talking about what you learn on the journey in psychology. And it wasn't our original A-plan to talk about that, but it was such an organic, fluid, lovely chat that we decided that we'd do what was our a plan as a follow-up episode because it's also such an incredibly important conversation to have so we first met on linkedin phil and it's fair to say that i'm now going to be your groupie and follow everything you do and like and comment and share even more because i'm like oh phil is
你可能还记得我们在播客第 113 期中的聊天，当时菲尔和我讨论了你在心理学求学之路上学到了什么。讨论这个话题其实并不是我们最初的 A 计划，但那次聊天是如此自然、流畅且美妙，以至于我们决定把这作为后续节目来实现我们最初的计划，因为这也是一个极其重要的对话。我们最初是在领英（LinkedIn）上认识的菲尔，可以说我现在要成为你的粉丝团成员，关注你所做的一切，甚至更多地给你点赞、评论和转发，因为我觉得，噢，菲尔现在
now my best friend so you're a trainee clinical psychologist and we first met on LinkedIn. Could you tell everybody a little bit about how it was that our paths crossed and what you were doing on LinkedIn? Of course yeah so as as you said Marianne I am in my final year of training now, and I'm currently conducting a piece of research as part of my doctoral thesis. Yeah, we met on LinkedIn because I was sort of in the middle of trying to promote and advertise my research study far and wide. And yes, I think you spotted it on there and you were like, yes, let's talk about that because this is an important topic. But going back a bit to my first year of training that's when we were kind of encouraged to start
是我的最好朋友了。所以，你是一名临床心理学实习生，我们最初是在领英上认识的。能跟大家简单聊聊我们的轨迹是如何交汇的，以及当时你在领英上做什么吗？当然可以，如你所说，玛丽安，我现在处于培训的最后一年，目前正在进行一项作为博士论文一部分的研究。对，我们在领英上相遇是因为我当时正在尽力广泛地宣传和推广我的研究。是的，我想你当时在上面看到了，然后你就说，是的，我们来聊聊这个吧，因为这是一个重要的话题。不过回溯到我的第一年培训，那时候我们被鼓励开始
thinking about what we wanted to do research-wise and to pick at least two supervisors for the thesis based on their research interests and yours. And the thing is that at the very beginning of my training I didn't really know what I wanted to do because there's so much you know out there that you can do and I think you know as the months kind of went went on I was sort of thinking to myself I want to do something on LGBTQ plus community and mental health and you know being being a gay man myself it's something that I'm probably very passionate about and biased in that sort of sense but I felt that it's a very important topic especially with the current kind of cultural,
思考我们在研究方面想做的事情，并根据他们和你的研究兴趣为论文选择至少两位导师。问题是，在培训刚开始的时候，我真的不知道自己想做什么，因为有太多你可以去探索的方向了。我想随着时间的推移，几个月过去了，我开始在心里盘算：我想做一个关于 LGBTQ+ 社区和心理健康的研究。考虑到我自己是一名男同性恋者，这可能是我非常有热情且带有某种偏见的主题，但我认为这是一个非常重要的课题，特别是考虑到目前全球围绕这个社区的各种文化、
social, political environment worldwide around this community. And I was thinking to myself, I want to do something for a particular population. But again, I didn't quite know in my first year exactly what I was doing. And I was thinking it was towards the end and the beginning of the second year
社会和政治环境。我当时想为某个特定群体做点事情。但同样，在第一年的时候，我并不十分清楚自己在做什么。我想那是接近第一年尾声到第二年刚开始的时候，
when I kind of had a more concrete thing in mind. So I'm not sure how it works with other courses, but in our course, the thesis is kind of broken down into two chapters or parts or sections, whatever you want to call them. The first one is like a systematic review that you do on a like literature, and then you critique that literature. And the second one is an empirical kind of study that you carry out, and then you write it up as a report. And ideally, both of these should be on a similar topic, not carbon copy of each other but you know similar sort of topic so my systematic review that i'm currently writing up is on the relationship between self-compassion and help seeking in men specifically so that's you know men worldwide but my study, the one that you saw Marianne online on LinkedIn,
我心中才有了更具体的想法。我不确定其他课程是如何运作的，但在我们的课程中，毕业论文大体上分为两个章节、部分或板块，随便你怎么称呼它们。第一部分是对文献进行的系统性回顾（systematic review），然后你需要对这些文献进行批判性评估。第二部分是你开展的一项实证研究（empirical study），然后将其写成报告。理想情况下，这两部分应该围绕相似的主题，不是互相复印的那种，但你知道，是类似的主题。所以我目前正在撰写的系统性回顾是关于男性自我同情与求助行为之间的关系的，特别是针对男性的研究。所以这是面向全球男性的研究。而我的研究——也就是你在领英上看到的玛丽安的那项研究，
that's specifically for adult gay men. It's kind of evaluating the effectiveness of a compassionate mind training, which is online on different sorts of psychological outcome measures, including help seeking, compassion, internalized homophobia, and shame. So yeah, it's like a randomized controlled trial. So it's open to any adult gay men over the age of 18. They don't need to be UK nationals. They could be from any part of the world as long as they have a sufficient level of English. Those are basically the only requirements for it.
则是专门针对成年男同性恋者的。它旨在评估一种在线同情心训练（compassionate mind training）对各种心理结果指标的有效性，这些指标包括求助行为、同情心、内化同性恋恐惧症（internalized homophobia）和羞耻感。所以是的，这就像是一项随机对照试验（randomized controlled trial）。因此，它对所有 18 岁以上的成年男同性恋者开放。他们不需要是英国国民。只要他们的英语水平足够好，来自世界任何地方都可以。这基本上是唯一的两项要求。
And what they do is they all complete a set of questionnaires at the beginning, they're all online. And at the end of those questionnaires, they get assigned to one of two conditions. So the reader is going to be assigned to the Compassionate Mind Training condition or to Control condition. And if they're in the Compassionate Mind Training condition, they get sent daily links to different practices over the course of 14 days or two weeks the people in the control condition don't get sent anything during that period and then both of these groups complete the same set of questionnaires so two weeks after they've completed the very first set and then another two weeks pass and then completely the same questionnaires for
他们要做的是在开始时完成一套问卷，这些问卷全都是在线填写的。在完成这些问卷后，他们会被分配到两种条件（condition）中的一种。也就是说，参与者会被分配到同情心训练条件组或对照组。如果他们被分在同情心训练条件组，他们会在 14 天或两周内每天收到指向不同练习的链接；而对照组的人在这期间不会收到任何东西。接着，这两组人在完成最初的那套问卷两周后，会再次完成完全相同的一套问卷；然后又过两周，他们需要第三次也是最后一次完成完全相同的问卷。所以这就像是一个为期两周的追踪问卷调查阶段。
the third and final time so it's like a two-week sort of follow then completely the same questionnaires for the third and final time. So it's like a two week sort of follow up set of questionnaires. And the people who are in a control condition who didn't have access to those practices, they get access to all of them all together after they've completed the third and final set of their questionnaires. And at the very end, people can opt in for a prize draw. I'm trying to remember how many. So basically it's like, yeah, Amazon vouchers that they can opt in for a prize draw I'm trying to remember how many so basically it's like yeah Amazon vouchers that they can opt in for they can say yes or no to that and that's essentially it and I'm yeah I'm still in the recruitment stage of that I have started kind of writing up some of
然后完全相同的问卷进行第三次也是最后一次。所以这就类似于一个两周的追踪问卷调查阶段。而那些处于对照组、没有接触到这些练习的人，在他们完成第三次也是最后一次问卷后，会一次性获得所有这些练习的权限。在最后，参与者可以选择是否参加抽奖。我努力回想一下数量。基本上就是，是的，他们可以选择加入亚马逊代金券（Amazon vouchers）的抽奖，他们可以选择“是”或“否”。基本上就是这样，而我目前还在招募阶段。无论如何，在我看到结果之前，我已经开始撰写报告中我可以先动笔的部分了。但希望我能招募到更多的参与者，因为我估算过，理想情况下我大约需要 140 到 150 人左右。是的，我离这个数字还有点距离，但正在慢慢接近。好的，我会确保当这期节目发布时调整一下日期，以便我们提前发布。
the bits of the report that I can start writing up before I see the results anyway but hopefully I can get even more participants because I think I calculated I need around 140, 150 ideally. Yeah, and I'm still not very, very close to that. But getting there slowly. Okay, I will make sure that we tweak the dates when this is going to come out. So we bring it forward.
这可能会——我猜会的。我们的第一期是 113 期，我会把这期安排在那之后不久，这样我们就能最大限度地让听众参与进来，或者向他们团队或家里的其他人提起这件事。这是仅限英国，还是潜在的国际性的？有什么限制吗？任何人只要年满 18 岁，
So it will probably, I guess, yeah, it's going to. So our first one was 113. I'll make this one shortly after that so that we can hopefully yeah maximize people listening being able to take part or mention it to people in their teams or their families and is it uk is it potentially international what what are the limits anyone so the as long as they're above the age of 18 or above the age of 18 and identify as a gay man, that's basically it. Yeah. So they don't need to be living in the UK. They don't need to be UK nationals as long as they have a sufficient level of English to engage with the questionnaires and the practices.
年龄在 18 岁或以上，并且认同自己是男同性恋，基本上就可以了。是的。所以他们不需要住在英国，也不需要是英国国民，只要他们的英语水平足以应付问卷和练习就行了。基本上就是这样。谢谢。你在录制前以及刚才的录制过程中也亲口告诉我，你自己是一名男同性恋者。在心理学领域，这是一种怎样的体验？这在与来访者的交往中会出现吗？还是说并不会出现？你知道，我戴着结婚戒指，但我可能和一个女性结婚了，这并不必然意味着我是异性恋还是同性恋。但这对你来说是怎样的体验呢？这是一个好问题。我想我只是在思考培训方面的事，即临床培训。
That's basically it. Yeah. Thank you. And you told me yourself before the recording and obviously during this recording that you are a gay man yourself how how is that in psychology and how does that crop up with clients or does it not crop up with clients you know I wear a wedding ring but I could be married to a woman you know it doesn't you know it doesn't necessarily mean that I'm heterosexual or I'm gay but how has that been for you? Yeah good question I guess I'm just sort of thinking in terms of the training the clinical training
从学术角度来看，作为一个课程和同辈群体，我们经常会思考社会风俗（social graces），比如性别和性取向等，以及这意味着什么——不仅关于你是谁，还关于它如何影响和塑造你与他人合作的方式。我经常会思考这些问题。当我们在临床实践中进行此类讨论时，比如在实习期间，如果话题自然而然地涉及到了 LGBTQ+ 相关的话题，我对同事们一直是坦诚的。我不会无缘无故地说：“顺便说一句，我是个男同性恋，所以……”
from an academic point of view as a course and as a cohort we've often sort of thought about the social graces so sort of gender and sexual orientation etc and what that means in terms of you know who you are but also how that affects and influences the way you work with other people so I've often sort of thought about that you know we've been fairly open within the cohort when we've had discussions like that within clinical practice let's say on placements I have been open with my colleagues about it when it has you know come I'm just sort of trying to think when it would have come naturally let's say if we've talked about kind of the topic of LGBT in some sense or another I wouldn't just sort of say by the way you know I'm I'm a gay man so this is yeah
所以，嗯，我觉得这不像你需要向每个实习点出柜一样。这只是说，正如我会说我丈夫的名字一样，你会说你伴侣的名字。由他们去把这些点连起来，而不是让你去让这个过程变得更容易。事情就是这样，你就是你，这些就是关于你的事实。与同事相处时，希望能建立持久的治疗性工作关系，有时甚至是友谊，你绝对应该感到有力量去展现真实的自己。
so um yeah I don't think it's not like you need to come out to each place yeah it's just that you say you know in the same way that I would say my husband's name, you would say your partner's name. And it's, you know, it's up for them to join up the dots. It's not for you to help make that process easier. You know, it is what it is. You are who you are. And these are the facts of you. with your colleagues and hopefully form lasting therapeutic working relationships and sometimes even friendships you know you absolutely should feel hopefully empowered to just be yourself
确实是的。正如你所说，我可能会说：“哦，是的，我和我的伴侣去了某某地方，他做了这个或说了那个，”然后他们就可以从语境中猜出来。但如果他们好奇并想更多地了解我的伴侣，我可能会展开多说一点，比如“你们是什么时候或在哪里认识的？”诸如此类。至于来访者，我认为这就要棘手一些，因为显然在那种情况下，你周围会有各种伦理考量。甚至，提及这些是否合适？我为什么要在一开始就提起它呢？我只是在想，我到目前为止经历过的实习点并不是最多元化的地区，所以
exactly yeah and as you said yeah I might just say oh yeah my partner and I went to whatever and he did or said this and you know they can then guess from the context but yeah I don't feel obliged to be saying it to people if they're curious and they want to learn more about my partner then I might kind of expand on that or oh when did you guys meet or where did you meet that sort of thing in terms of patience yeah I think that's a bit trickier because obviously in there you've got sorts of ethical considerations around that and you know even you know would it be appropriate to even mention that why why would I mention it in the first place and I'm just sort of thinking the placements I've had so far haven't been kind of in the most diverse areas so I have
我也对此进行了反思——这意味着我没有接触到很多我可能本可以与之合作的 LGBTQ+ 社区成员。但确实，我想我并没有向任何来访者提及我的性取向。而且我也在想，是因为我不确定在什么语境下会提起它吗？虽然它也可能会出现。但我认为我在面对来访者时会更加有所保留。我想我在培训期间大概也是如此。我想大概只有在取得资格认证之后，我才偶尔会提到“丈夫”，以及思考关系的复杂性。
reflected on that as well what that's meant in terms of me not having seen a lot of the sort of LGBTQ plus community that I might have been working with but yeah I don't think I have you know mentioned my sexuality my sexual orientation to uh to any clients and again I'm sort of thinking to myself is it because you know I'm not sure what sort of context it would have come up I could come up anyway but yeah I think I'm a bit sort of more guarded in terms of that with clients. And I think probably the same would have been true of me during training as well. I think it's only probably since being qualified that I probably do occasionally mention husband, you know, and, you know, thinking of just about the intricacies of relationships, you know,
当然我并不是在谈论很多细节，而只是当你们住在一起时，有时事情确实会很棘手，因为你们可能会想要不同的东西，有不同的期望。仅仅是在那种语境下提及。但我完全知道，特别是如果有人身处动态的服务环境中，那是不可能的。但随着你在职业生涯中不断前行，随着你最终可能会开始与经历过死产、晚期流产、怀孕甚至失去孩子的家庭合作——这纯粹是因为这是她经历过的事情，你知道的，我想那是七年前的事了——所以它可能会塑造你。它在未来可能会变得相关，即使现在不是。但我喜欢这是属于你的一部分，你知道的，我希望你为自己感到骄傲。有那么多值得骄傲的事情，所以我真的希望你是这样。并且，希望你身边环绕着那些同样为能成为你的同事、朋友和伴侣而感到骄傲的人。
and I'm obviously not talking in great detail, but just, you know, when you do live with someone, it can be tricky sometimes, you know, because you might want different things, you have different expectations and, you know, and just to mention in that sort of context, but I absolutely know that that's, you know, especially if someone is in a dynamic service, that ain't happening, you know. But it's as you move forward in your career and as, you know, you may end up working with families who have experienced stillbirth or late miscarriage or pregnancy or even child loss. And that was purely because that's something that she experienced, you know, I think it was seven years ago. And so it may shape you. It may be relevant in future, even if it's not now. But I love that it's something, it's just part of you, you know, I hope you feel proud of yourself. And there's so much to be proud of. So I really hope you do. And that, you know, hopefully you're surrounded by people who also feel proud to be your colleague and your friend and your partner too. Thank you yeah and I'm really blessed in that sense that you know everyone's been really accepting of me because it wasn't until you
谢谢。是的，在这方面我真的很幸运，每个人都非常接纳我，因为直到我生活中的晚期，我才真正对自己和他人出柜。我曾多次对别人说，对自己出柜比对他人出柜要难得多。而且我知道在之前的播客中我们曾聊过我的出身背景，以及某些事情周围的文化心态。所以，我来自保加利亚，那里的人们仍然抱持着——相当一部分人仍然抱持着相当恐同、种族主义、性别歧视的观点。在那种环境中长大，作为一个孩子，你可能不会觉得这有什么有害的，并且它很容易在那种文化中被正常化。但作为成年人长大后，我开始意识到，天哪，这些其实全都不对劲，
know later on in life when I did come out both to myself and to other people and I've said so many times to other people that coming out to myself is so much harder than coming out to other people and I know then the previous podcast we sort of spoke about where I come from and you know kind of the cultural mentality around certain things. So, you know, I come from Bulgaria, where people still hold, quite a few people still hold a very sort of homophobic, you know, racist, sexist sort of views, which, you know, growing up in that environment as a child, you might not really think it's anything sort of, you know, harmful, and it could get easily sort of normalized within that culture. But as growing up as an adult, I'm sort of realizing, gosh, none of this was,
也不是真正可以接受的。我想这可能就是我刚才提到在面对来访者时那种有所保留的原因所在——我内心的一部分并没有 100% 感到自在。比如说，和我的伴侣手牵手，我在哪里会觉得这样做很自在呢？许多异性恋伴侣可能根本不会去考虑这些问题。对我来说，这突然变成了一种去权衡不同类型羞耻感的事情——既有外部羞耻感也有内部羞耻感，还有内化的同性恋恐惧症。我知道有些人可能不太清楚这是什么，但大家大概都知道什么是同性恋恐惧症；而内化则发生在当你把它转向自身时，你会觉得身为同性恋或做自己并不是真正可以接受的，觉得这其中存在某种道德上的错误，或者你会为此感到羞耻——不仅仅是对自己，还对更广泛的社区感到羞耻。你知道，这会对人们的
you know, really okay. And I think that's probably where I mentioned that guardedness earlier with sort of clients where part of me isn't 100% sort of comfortable. So let's say holding hands with my partner, you know, where would I feel comfortable doing that? Something that lots of straight couples might not even think about at all. For me, all of a sudden it becomes quite a sort of looking at is kind of measuring different types of shame so both external and internal shame but also internalized homophobia which I know some people might not quite know what that is but I guess people know what homophobia is but internalizes when it's kind of you are turning it towards yourself and you are sort of feeling that being gay or being who you are isn't really okay that there's some sort of moral wrong about it or that you're ashamed of it not just of yourself but of the kind of wider community and you know that can have a big effect on people's
心理健康产生巨大的影响。但我想随着年龄的增长，我开始觉得：我才懒得去管这些破事儿呢。你知道的，关于在到处都控制自己行为的这些事，我决定只做我自己。我不会随随便便逢人就倾倒关于我是谁的隐私。我可能仍然会保留某种程度的有所保留，这可以理解，是源于过去和那种文化心态。但我也将转而追求快乐、忠于自我，而不是一味地隐瞒。绝对是这样。这让我想起有一次我丈夫和我在考虑去迪拜，但当时我们还没有结婚。那意味着，由于我们当时没结婚，我们不一定能够手拉手走在街上。你知道的，
mental health but I think as I grow older I'm sort of thinking to myself I can be bothered with some of this stuff you know about controlling myself everywhere I'm just going to be me older, I'm sort of thinking to myself, I can be bothered with some of this stuff, you know, about controlling myself everywhere. I'm just going to be me. You know, I'm not going to just tell willy nilly about who I am. I'm still probably going to have some of that gardeness, which is, you know, kind of understandably come from that past and from that sort of cultural mentality. But I'm also going to look towards being happy and true to myself rather than kind of concealing all the time. Absolutely. And it made me reflect upon a time that my husband and I were thinking about going to Dubai, but we weren't married at the time. And that, you know, we wouldn't necessarily have been able to walk hand in hand because we weren't married. And, you know,
不同的文化有不同的接受程度和不同的标准。而且，你知道的，你绝对会因为那种行为而惹上麻烦。作为一个在英国长大的异性恋女性（正如你现在所知，后来到了威尔士），这是我唯一的真实体验。但事实就是这样——做你自己却会因为做你自己而惹上麻烦，这真的很棘手。我目前正在读一本历史小说，故事设定在第二次世界大战之前，其中有针对不同国家的交叉叙事。对我来说，这听起来太迷人了。对于其他任何听众来说，这听起来可能既怪异又无聊。但它探讨了第一次世界大战后，在德国，为什么法西斯主义对德国民众变得如此具有吸引力和可接受性，为什么他们会如此欢迎希特勒。
different cultures have different levels of acceptance and different standards. And, you know, you can absolutely be, you know, you can get in trouble for that and that's my only real experience of that being a heterosexual woman having grown up in England and as you know now Wales but it's yeah it's being yourself but being in trouble for being yourself which is really tricky I'm reading a historical fiction book at the moment that's set before the Second World War, and there's split narratives for different countries. And to me, this sounds fascinating. To anyone else listening, that sounds really weird and boring. But it's looking at how in the post First World War period, Germany, why fascism became so appealing and acceptable to the German people, why they were so welcoming of Hitler.
但作为其中的一部分，法西斯运动签署者中的不同派系对人们的所有攻击，包括用极其可怕的方式伤害甚至谋杀男同性恋者。这让我不禁感叹：天哪，我太高兴我们目前没有那种情况了，而且现在有了更多的包容，人们希望能够更自在地做自己。然后我刷手机看推特时，看到有人发了一张照片，是一个男人的朋友，他在英国仅仅因为是同性恋就被残忍且野蛮地殴打了。当时我就觉得，天哪，这让我感到非常难过。
But as part of that, all of the kind of attacks against people by different factions who were signed up to the fascist movement included kind of hurting and sometimes murdering gay men in really horrendous ways. And that was making me think, gosh, I'm so pleased that we don't have that currently and that there's been more inclusion and that people can hopefully feel more comfortable being themselves. And then I was on my phone and I was on Twitter and I saw that someone had posted a photo of their friend, of a man who had been viciously and savagely beaten in the UK for being gay. And I was like, God, we made me feel really sad.
就好像在很多方面，情况根本没有进步。而且，你知道的，这只是我从外部视角来看的感受。这太不公平了，也不对，菲尔。这真的很悲哀，不是吗？正如你刚才所说，你可能会仅仅因为你是谁而陷入大麻烦。在某些国家的法律中，我甚至可能会被关起来或杀死。仅凭这个想法本身就让我感到恐惧，同时也让我为所有可能生活在那样环境和国家里的人感到难过。你知道，他们的日常生活是什么样的？如果我在英国对于在街上和伴侣手拉手都有这种程度的有所保留，我甚至无法想象如果我生活在那种环境中会是什么样子。这真的、真的很悲哀。
Like, things haven't moved on in so many ways. And, you know, that's just me from an outside perspective. And, you know, it's just not fair and it's not right Phil. It's really sad isn't it and as you were saying earlier like you could get in serious trouble just for just for being who I am I could be locked up or killed in certain countries legally so according to their law that thought in itself just terrifies me, but also makes me sad about all these people who might be living in environments in countries like that. You know, what do they, what does their day-to-day life look like? You know, if I have that level of gardeners in the UK
确实如此。我想这就是为什么研究如此重要。因为研究可以超越不同的文化、不同的国家。我希望这能为你的研究带来广泛的影响。我希望你能将其广泛传播，让人们开始思考同理心的重要性、接纳的重要性，以及仅仅允许人们做自己的重要性——无论你是谁，这都没有任何区别。这没有任何影响。你应该允许别人做他们自己，让他们过自己的生活，这与你的生活毫无关系。你的信仰并不重要，你的感受并不重要，你被谁性吸引并不重要，你想做什么、不想做什么也不重要。如果别人想做他们想做的事，那很好。只要它是合法的、对他人无害的并且是双方自愿的，
about holding hands with my partner down the street, you know, what, I can't even begin to imagine what that would look like if I were living in one of those environments it's it's really really sad it is and I think this is why research matters you know it's because research can transcend different cultures different countries I hope that this goes far and wide for you. I hope that you disseminate it really widely and that people start to begin to think about the importance of compassion, the importance of acceptance, the importance of just allowing people to be who they are, regardless of who you are. That makes no difference. You know, you allow someone to be themselves and just, you know, get on with their life, which has no bearing on yours. It doesn't matter what you believe. It doesn't matter what you feel. It doesn't matter who you are sexually attracted to and what you want to do, what you don't want to do. If someone else wants to do what they want to do, just that's fine. As long as it's legal and not harmful to someone and it's consensual,
我们得加上这个前提。但是，你提出了一个非常好的观点，即实际上在某些国家它是不合法的。不过我猜我的意思是，针对目前的这个目的——在英国，它是合法的。那就放手让人们过自己的生活，做一个好人。保持善良，去寻找……或者就像我在英国长大时的那样：“如果你没有什么好听的话说，那就什么也别说。”是的，这真的让我作为一名心理学家去思考，那些攻击、霸凌、袭扰 LGBTQ+ 社区成员的人，他们的生活背后到底发生了什么？
you know, let's caveat that. But, you know, you make a really good point that actually in certain countries it isn't legal. But I guess what I'm meaning is for this purpose is UK, it is legal. And just leave people alone to live their lives, you know, and be a good person. be nice find you know or like when we when I was growing up in the UK it's like if you haven't got anything nice to say say nothing at all yeah it really makes me think as a psychologist what's going on behind those people's lives the ones who
因为我总是说，人们不会无缘无故地在某天醒来，然后感觉或做出这样的行为：“你知道吗，我今天真的很想去痛殴一个男同性恋。”作为一个心理学家，去观察他们为什么会有那种想法或做出那样的行为，总是很有趣的。你知道，他们是在什么样的环境中长大的？他们接受了什么样的叙事和价值观？举个例子，我目前在一个法医心理学环境（forensic setting）中与成年人工作。我认为，我们在那里合作的一些人有着法医心理学历史（forensic histories），他们曾犯下罪行。我想人们常常会把他们打上罪犯的标签，认为他们是坏人，是他们自己选择那样做的。
are attacking bullying assaulting members of the LGBTQ plus community, because I always keep saying that people don't wake up one day feeling or doing something like, do you know what I really feel like beating, you know, a gay man up today? Like, it's always interesting, especially as a psychologist to see, well, how come they are thinking that or doing that? You know, what kind of environment did they grow up in? What kind of narratives and values have they endorsed just for example i'm working in a forensic setting at the moment working with adults and i think you know some of the people we work with there have forensic histories they've committed crimes and i think people could often think you know just brand them as criminals like they're bad people they chose to do that and you know it's brand them as criminals, like they're bad people, they chose to do that. And, you know, it's really helpful, actually, in displacement to kind of unravel what's been
把他们打上罪犯的标签，认为他们是坏人，是他们选择那样做的。而实际上，在这个实习点，去厘清这个人身上到底发生了什么，是非常有帮助的。因为同样地，他们并没有在某一天醒来就觉得想去犯罪或做其他什么事。这太迷人了，真的非常迷人。而且这里面有一种非常“去羞耻感”（de-shaming）的东西——我不知道该如何用语言表达那种能够公开讨论这些事情的感受，特别是在住院环境中，他们大部分时间里日复一日地看到相同的员工，这种体验真的非常、非常有力。同样地，对于这些人，我也非常好奇：为什么这些壁垒依然存在？正如你所说，这就是研究能够真正发挥巨大作用的地方。
going on for this person. Because, yet again, they didn't wake up one day just feeling like they wanted to commit this crime or do whatever. And it's fascinating, it really is. And there's something very de-shaming, I'm not sure how to kind of verbalize it about being able to talk about that especially in an inpatient environment where they see kind of staff the same staff day in and day out for most of the time and yeah and it's really really powerful so similarly yeah with these people I'm very curious to know why are these barriers still there and as you said yeah this is where research can really really help. It. And there's so much trauma in forensic services. And all of my assistant work was in forensic services.
在法医心理学服务中存在着如此多的创伤。我所有的助理工作都是在法医心理学服务中进行的。虽然我们无法重做我们已经做过的事，但我希望当我身处那些环境时，我能拥有更多的以创伤为重点的视角和理解。因为我认为，如果没有创伤这个因素，我们的许多法医心理学环境可能会是空空如也的。创伤的力量如此强大且具有预测性，它渗透到了如此多的心理健康服务中。这确实是事实，菲尔。再次非常感谢你抽出时间，我知道我占用了比我预先宣传的更多的时间。每一分钟我都乐在其中，谢谢你。这真是一件愉快且荣幸的事。如果人们想联系你，
And, you know, whilst we can't redo what we've already done, I wish I'd had more of a trauma-focused lens and understanding when I was in those settings. Because I think that without trauma, I think a lot of our forensic settings would probably be empty. You know, it so so powerful and predictive it permeates and so many mental health settings trauma it really does phil thank you so much again for your time and i know i've taken up more of it than than i advertised on the tin i enjoyed every minute of it thank you it's been such a pleasure and a privilege. And if people did want to get in contact with you to kind of think about
比如考虑参与你的研究，我猜这全都是在线进行的？他们不需要亲自见你。对，全都在线进行。这就是它的美妙之处。那么，对他们来说最好的联系方式是什么？是领英，还是你想引导大家去其他地方？是的，如果他们想的话，可以通过领英联系我。
an interest in taking part in your research, I'm presuming it's all online. They don't need to meet you in person. No, it's all online. That's the beauty of it. Yeah. And where's the best place for them to do that? Is that LinkedIn or is there somewhere else you'd rather direct people to? Yeah, they can reach out to me on LinkedIn if they want to.
如果通过我的大学电子邮箱，可能会更简单一些。我不知道你是否能在播客下方添加内容？我绝对会这么做。是的，所以如果你告诉我邮箱是什么，当我们说出来时，它会确保显示在屏幕上。你的邮箱地址是什么，菲尔？菲尔，邮箱是 p.d.pampalove@soton.ac.uk。太完美了，非常感谢。而且我相信你在领英上的名字是菲利普·帕姆普洛夫（Philip Pamperlove），如果这对人们来说更方便的话。是的，因为我叫你菲利普时，你当时的表情就像是“我觉得我惹上麻烦了”。我能叫你菲尔吗？你当然可以叫菲尔。绝对叫我菲尔。好的，没问题。
It might be easier if they do it on my university email address. I'm not sure if you're able to put stuff underneath your podcast. I absolutely will. Yes. So if you tell me what that is, we'll make sure it appears on screen as we're saying it. What's your email address, Phil? phil it's p.d.pampalove at soton s-o-t-o-n dot a-c dot uk perfect thank you so much and you are i believe you're philip pampalove on linkedin if that's easier for people as well yeah because i called you philip you were like you're like i think i'm in trouble. Can I be Phil? Of course you can be Phil. Definitely call me Phil. Yeah. Okay. All right. It's been so lovely to speak with you and wishing you well with your research. Please let me know if I can be of assistance with anything in future. And yeah,
能和你交谈真是太愉快了，祝你的研究一切顺利。如果未来有什么我可以帮上忙的，请随时告诉我。真的非常荣幸。谢谢你。同样地。非常感谢，玛丽安。不客气。哦，我真是太喜欢菲尔了。老实说，我觉得和他交流太有趣了。事后在镜头外我不得不对他说：“别担心，我不会突然出现在你家街道尽头，你是安全的，没事的。”我非常期待看到他的职业生涯走向何方，也期待听到他的研究进展。当然，如果你确实想参与那项研究，请考虑联系他。详细信息将放在节目介绍中，你也可以在领英上找到他。
it's just been a real privilege. Thank you so much. Likewise. Thank you very much, Marianne. So welcome. Oh, I just love Phil. I honestly just think he's so interesting to speak to. And I did have to say to him off camera afterwards, don't worry, I'm not going to suddenly turn up like at the end of your street, like you are safe. It's okay. I'm really excited to see where his career goes and to hear how his research does. And obviously, if you do want to get involved with that research, please do consider reaching out to him. The details will be in the show notes or you can also find him on LinkedIn.
如果你有任何你认为可以做成精彩播客节目的主题，请不要害羞，快来联系我吧。最简单的方法是通过我的社交媒体。我在所有平台上都是 Dr Marianne Trent。如果你在 YouTube 上观看，屏幕上会出现一个二维码。至于其他平台，只需在你的首选社交媒体中输入“Dr Marianne Trent”即可。我坚信我在所有地方都存在。所以，快来订阅吧。在 TikTok 上关注我，在 Facebook 上关注我，在 Instagram 上关注我。
If you have got any topics that you think might make brilliant podcast episodes, please don't be shy. Do come and get in contact with me. The easiest way to do that is via my social. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. There will be a QR code on screen if you are watching on YouTube. For everywhere else, literally just type in Dr. Marianne Trent into socials of your choice. I do believe I'm everywhere. So yeah, come and subscribe. Follow me on TikTok. Follow me on Facebook. Follow me on Instagram.
做所有这些美好的事情。顺便说一句，如果你是通过 MP3、Spotify 或 Apple 听节目的，如果你恰好有那么一会儿空闲，请考虑给我留个评论或评分，那将是对我莫大的鼓舞。快来加入免费的心理学 Facebook 群组——由玛丽安·特伦特博士创立的“有志心理学家社群”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community）。去看看这些书：《有志心理学家文集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家文集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。无论是在面试季，还是无论你何时收听这期节目——这可能也是申请季——这两本书对你来说都可以是非常有用的反思工具。它们真的非常有助于你思考自己跨越整个人生阶段的发展。它们能为你引发有趣的思考和个人反思，所以一定要去看看。
Do all those good things. Whilst you're at it, if you are listening on MP3, Spotify or Apple, please do consider leaving me a review or rating if if you've only got a short moment that would be so gratefully come and join the free psychology facebook group the aspiring psychologist community with dr marianne trent check out the books the aspiring psychologist collective and the clinical psychologist collective they can both be really reflective tools for you at interview time of year, or whenever you're listening to this, it might be application time of year as well. They're just really good for helping you think about your own developments across your lifespan. They can provoke interesting food for thought and personal reflections for you. So do check them out.
去亚马逊上看看吧。所有这些详细信息都在节目介绍中。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待在我们的下一期节目中与你重聚，节目将于下周一早上 6 点上线。保重。在这个播客中，我为你的即将获得资格认证而感到难过。这里是“有志心理学家”（The Aspiring Psychologist）。我叫雅娜（Yana），是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家文集》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。成为临床心理学家竟然有这么多不同的途径，这让我感到非常惊奇，而且并没有成为其中一员的“完美方式”。这让我充满了信心：不，我并没有做错，这也减轻了我自身的压力。所以，如果你对
Check them out on Amazon. All these details in the show notes. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode, which will be along from Monday at 6am. Take care. with this podcast i feel sad to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist my name is yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about
成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
成为一名临床心理学家，我绝对推荐这一点，只是为了让你自己安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。